foreign
has built a platform that has given
humans an opportunity to innovate like
never before we rely on AI for things
like Gmail reply prompts Amazon purchase
recommendations Spotify music
suggestions and even schedule
appointments AI analyzes various
behavioral aspects such as past
playlists browsing history and previous
orders to create accurate behavioral
models to give you a perfect
recommendation that pops up right on
your screen welcome back everyone in
today's video we have an exciting topic
to discuss that will revolutionize the
way you compose emails in our Digital
World effective communication is crucial
and Google has just unveiled a game
changing feature for Gmail users that is
help me write join us as we delve into
the remarkable capabilities of help me
write feature in Gmail now if you are
someone who is interested in building a
career in artificial intelligence and
machine learning while graduating from
the best universities or a professional
Wireless sets to switch careers with
artificial intelligence while learning
from the experts then try giving a show
that the simply learns postgraduate
program in artificial intelligence from
the Purdue University that is in
collaboration with IBM the course link
is mentioned in the description box and
you can navigate to the home page where
you can find a complete overview of the
program being offered by simpler take
action up skill and get ahead now we'll
get introduced with the help me write
feature so communication has become an
increasingly digital an email is at the
Forefront of Connecting People worldwide
however we often find ourselves spending
excessive time crafting emails but fret
not Google's latest announcement at the
Google I O event brings a groundbreaking
solution that Innovation is help me
write feature that is integrated in
Gmail and that would be rolled out for
all the users but currently it's rolled
out for some specific users and if we
talk about it is powered by Advanced
artificial intelligence this remarkable
tool goes beyond mere suggestions
as you type help me write to an
intelligently recommends relevant
phrases complete sentences and even
entire paragraphs to help you express
your thoughts effortlessly and
effectively now we'll see how we can
Unleash the Power of help me right let's
explore the incredible capabilities of
help me write feature imagine sitting at
your desk staying at a blank email drop
struggling to find the right words with
help me write those days are behind you
this AI power tool not only suggests
suitable phrasing and sentence
structures but also acts as a personal
grammar and spelling assistant catching
those pesky errors but that's not all
help me write extended stabilities
Beyond language barriers you can
seamlessly translate your emails into
different languages facilitating
communication across diverse cultures
and regions now that we have understand
the potential of help me write let's
learn how to use this feature seamlessly
in Gmail when composing a new email all
you need to do is click on the help me
button that is the pen and Sparkle
button you can just see on the bottom
bar of Gmail window
so this feature is no rollout for all as
I have already told you but soon it will
be
and instantly when you just click on the
help me write function over the feature
and you just write a word or two telling
that we need to write the email for this
particular topic instantly the AI will
generate a draft based on your input
prompts and jump starting your email
composition
and once the graph is generated you have
complete control to personalize it
adjust the tone to form lies refine the
length with elaborate or shorten and
customize it to suit your needs help me
right and pass you to craft the perfect
image that reflects your style and
intentions
as this feature was told by Sundar
pichai C of Google and Google I O event
and this is how he used these features
to elaborate shorten and integrate some
emotions or what purpose he wants to
write this email over his intention
so as the feature is not rolled out we
have also taken reference from the
Google I O event which Sundar pichai had
for us
so now moving on let's dive deeper into
the various ways help me write can
enhance your email communication so this
feature is a game changer when it comes
to refining emails for instance imagine
you need to request a refund from an Ali
this example was also given by solar
pichai that you know is the CEO of
alphabet and that too in the Google I O
event 2023 and what this helped me write
2 it will draw from your past exchanges
with the airline and this tool will
create an entire main addressing the
refund request furthermore it offers
additional refinements as I told you it
will allow you to make the email more
formal then size or detail according to
your preference as you use the elaborate
options to write a detailed email now
efficiency is at the core of help me
write whether it's composing thank you
notes follow payments or professional
cover letters for job applications this
tool access a virtual assistant
seamlessly integrating with Gmail's
existing smart reply and smart compose
features I guess you guys have already
noticed these features and you have
definitely used them
so it empowers you to create these types
of emails swiftly and effectively
furthermore help me write helps you stay
organized by keeping track of email
templates additionally it acts as a
writing coach offering suggestions and
feedback to improve your writing skills
resulting in more polished and
professional emails now we'll see
benefits and best practices
so let's explore the wide-ranging
benefits of utilizing the help me write
feature in Gmail and some best practices
to maximize its potential first and
foremost help me write saves you
valuable time by generating email drafts
catering to both frequent event senders
and those who struggle with composing
emails moreover it ensures accuracy by
suggesting relevant phrases avoiding
grammatical and spelling errors that can
tarnish your message not only that but
help me write enhance his Clarity by
suggesting concise and easily
understandable language ensuring your
message is received exactly as intended
additionally it recommends persuasive
and impactful language making your
emails engaging and influential one of
the most significant advantages of help
me write is its ability to help you
reach a wider audience by suggesting
appropriate language for different
Target readers it ensures that your
emails are well received and understood
by recipients from diverse backgrounds
to make a moves out of this powerful
tool I would suggest you some key tips
so be specific and provide detailed
input to improve the quality of the text
generated additionally put effort into
editing the draft tailoring it to your
style and preferences lastly provide
feedback regularly to help the AI
improve and generate better email routes
now we'll see some limitations of help
me write feature while help me write is
an incredible tool it's important to
acknowledge its limitations here are a
few things to keep in mind firstly the
feature is still under development which
means it may not always generate
accurate or contextually appropriate
language it's essential to review and
use your own judgment to ensure the
generated text aligns with a specific
situation secondly while help me write
is a powerful AI tool it cannot replace
human judgment it lacks the full
understanding of context and wants human
communication therefore it's crucial to
employ your own judgment while utilizing
the generated text and ensure its
appropriateness lastly help me write his
primarily trained on English language
data making it most effective for fluent
English speakers no native English
speakers May face some challenges when
using this feature to its full potential
and there you have it the remarkable
help me write feature in Gmail that will
revolutionize the way we compose emails
this AI power tool not only saves time
and enhances accuracy but also assists
inefficient communication organization
and Improvement of our writing skills so
next time you find yourself staying at a
blank email draft why not give help me
write a prime it might just be the
helping hand you need to craft the
perfect image and what I think is Google
would probably integrate this feature in
Google Docs and maybe in its whole
workplace and Google chats let's hope
all the best and see what happens and
before signing over before signing off
let's check out what manova Learners has
to say about our courses we need to keep
updating your skills on a regular basis
no matter what level you're at I
recently completed the professional
certificate program in Ai and machine
learning from Simply learn in
partnership with Purdue University the
course material was comprehensive and
the faculty was extremely experienced
The Faculty was able to adjust their
teaching style in order to cater to the
overall skill set of the class in the
rapidly evolving world of technology
it's important to keep up Skilling for
every working professional stay relevant
continue learning if you find this video
helpful don't forget to hit the like
button and subscribe to our channel for
more exciting Tech updates see you next
time till then stay safe and keep
learning
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here
foreign